[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to the ice box
I'm gonna try and talk fast so we can
all go outside and warm up hi my name is
Sam I am based in New York City I'm a
data insights engineer I used to work
for flatter and health a lot of you
probably know about the company I spent
five and a half years there analyzing
the ecology data my background is
actually in academia and knowledge
representation automated reasoning so
I've done a lot of data modeling data
representation sort of on the
theoretical side and then ad flattered
and I spend five years just like
basically wearing every single hit you
could possibly imagine from data
engineering software engineering
automation data QA customer research
developing analytical packages standing
up web platforms
pretty much anything my expertise is
like lesson big data so everyone always
talks about Big Data it's more like
artisanal handcrafted data and it's also
less focus on like actual data science
so I don't do like heavy machine
learning stuff but more about subject
matter expertise and really sort of data
understanding you can follow me on
twitter @ SP bail I'm pretty active
there cool um so how did this talk come
about I am Lachie quoting my own tweet
here I went to a machine learning
conference earlier this year and I heard
a lot it was really funny because
there's kind of a split between sort of
two types of speakers one group was from
academia and they said oh look at us
we've built this awesome model with this
data and and they were really excited
about it and then there was sort of a
Friday afternoon slot was more like
healthcare data scientists from industry
and I said well this is all really
difficult and it's kind of brutal and
you really need two main experts
understand whether you're actually doing
and your users probably won't trust you
and adoption is viddy hard and I thought
it was such a funny contradiction
between the two different types of
experience that I decided to
sort of share my own experience that
I've had at Flatiron health um and
generally working in health care data
over the past five years so just for the
structure of the talk I'm gonna first of
all just give you a very brief overview
of what I consider to be the vision of
healthcare data and AI talk about
problem number one which is messy data
problem number two reluctant users which
is at least from my perspective one of
the things that we sort of coming from
and I just assume most of us will be
coming from like a technical background
people from a technical background don't
always think of and then finally sort of
give you the light at the end of the
tunnel and talk a little bit about path
forward to get out of that mess so the
vision I for one welcome our robot
overlords so this is a very very
simplified version of what I consider to
be sort of the general vision maybe from
for people either coming from a clinical
background we're not that deep into
technology or sort of the general public
we're also a lot of people and
Technology who kind of get their hands
on data and think oh my god I can solve
this problem this is going to be amazing
so you have a patient patient has some
ailment patient goes to see a doctor
there's some diagnostics lots of
measurements that all generates a lot of
data right then we throw this at some
wonderful AI algorithm whatever the AI
flavor of the day is based on that the
patient gets recommended some form of
treatment whether that surgery or drugs
for example usually that of sort of
iterates like in a cycle where the
patient gets treated so my background so
it just as a sideline I worked in
oncology cancer treatment and usually
for cancer treatment it's not just you
take one drug for like a week and then
you're done but it's a very cyclical
sort of treatment we have cycles we get
chemotherapy infusions for example once
a month or every few weeks over the
course of several months so in that
context you get you treatment that has
some impact on a patient there's more
diagnostics right you take more lab
tests to see how the tumor for example
grown or shrunken what's the blood
values look like
and that generates more data and and
then you can plug into any AI and see
maybe there's a new treatment or maybe
this treatment is going great right at
the same time we also assumed that all
this information that feeds into our
data set whatever this nebulous data set
is also then gets shared and so we can
learn from that for other patients so
that's actually what lies in the Lea's
and the key note just talked about kind
of this whole like having a population
and then deriving some entailments from
that population for the individual right
so this is sort of the general hope that
we have for artificial intelligence and
in healthcare and then obviously at the
end the patient is cured and ideally if
those feeds into sort of a bigger data
set and a bigger learning system lots of
other patients will be cured based on
that too cool so that's a hope one of
the most prominent examples at least
from my perspective again kind of with
an oncology lens over the past few years
everyone's probably heard of IBM Watson
I remember was it was very very
prominent example of sort of people
having really really high hopes about
this whole learning from in that case
mostly from literature and then
recommending treatment for patients and
improving treatment outcomes starting in
2011 over 50 organizations and this is
don't like this take this with a grain
of salt this is me just counting sort of
press announcements but around 50
organizations announced collaborations
with IBM Watson by 2017 again based on
the the data that I have if anyone from
is here from IBM Watson who has better
numbers like please do tell me please do
correct me but from what I've seen from
kind of what I clicked around and
research only about five projects out of
a sample of 24 that I looked at had
actually been launched so there's a lot
of high hopes and not a lot of actual
implementation or not a lot of actual
sort of production there's an app in the
UK as called babylon health so for
context I used to live in England so I'm
also very interested in the NHS and
things that are going on across the pond
Babylon health is a patient-facing app
that provides an AI chat bot to triage
sentence so if you do work in healthcare
you probably aware that one of the kind
of topics that's very interesting for
people in healthcare is avoiding or
preventing hospitalizations having
people go to hospital to the emergency
room is extremely expensive and in most
cases or in a lot of cases actually not
necessary so we want to try and avoid
that so having an AI chat bot that can
trash symptoms and then tell people
whether they really need to go to the to
the emergency room or whether they can
baby
stay at home we're just like wait until
they can see a general practitioner the
next day is an extremely helpful measure
Babylon actually has two contracts with
the NHS in the UK so there seems to be a
lot of recognition that this might
actually be helpful but also physicians
actually voiced concerns about the
accuracy of those diagnoses and
depending on whether you have false
positives or false negatives in that
case you can have sort of you know
either you're wasting money or you're
putting potentially putting someone's
lives at risk
so regardless of whether the whether you
have false positives or false negatives
in that case like wrong diagnoses are
actually just pretty bad so to just sum
up sort of the introduction um
there's been a lot of hopes and there's
a ton of other examples that it can Navy
you um just one thing for you to think
about and maybe I'm just like really
missing the thing here but I asked a
bunch of people as I was preparing to
talk what's the killer app that's in
production that's already sort of the
industry standard for healthcare and
artificial intelligence and I didn't
really get any answers if anyone can
actually naming one thing that's like
the go-to that's already in production
that's been proven and tested please do
let me know but it's sort of I feel like
everyone's like dancing around it and
really excited about it and it has a lot
of hopes but there's no like killer app
just yet so from my perspective there
are two sort of types of reasons as to
why these high hopes just didn't really
turn out and positively in reality first
of all there's a lot of technical
challenges around health care data in
particular and then secondly there's
also user acceptance challenge
challenges and makes like twenty minutes
or so I'm going to talk you through
those two aspects so healthcare data is
hard let's go shopping if anyone can
guess where my quotes are from please do
talk to me cool okay so fourthly for the
purpose of this talk I have a working
definition of healthcare data because
there's a lot of things you can imagine
there for my purpose this is any kind of
what I call real-world data that is
generated as part of a patient's and
clinicians interaction and that could
also involve other people but I'm
focusing mostly on patients and
clinicians with data capturing software
and medical devices for example medical
records so electronic medical record
systems or electronic health record
systems the software that your doctor
uses when you go and see a doctor
to document anything related to what's
your disease what are your what's your
blood pressure your BMI what kind of
medication are you currently taking what
are they prescribing you all these
things are certain an electronic medical
record system electronic health record
system I use them interchangeably any
sort of scans for example lap and
pathology report reports billing records
chat interactions there's chat BOTS with
your providers for example device data
fitbit's of course or like the most
famous one there etc etc so that's my
definition of healthcare data real world
data basically one big thing the reason
why I'm saying that is because a lot of
times when you think about healthcare
data you also think about things like
drug discovery for example that's the
sort of pile I'm I won't be talking
about mostly because I'm not an expert
in that also because it's a complete
different different world obviously so
real world data is sort of my definition
of healthcare data all right
this is this is my favorite part I'm
like I said I spent five years just like
trying to figure out how to how to deal
with all the stuff so I'm like very
excited to to tell you about how awful
healthcare data is this is group therapy
for me great okay so first of all what
we have healthcare data we have
something they call structured and
unstructured data by structured data we
mean discrete data database fields so if
you look in the database and it says
first name or last name or social
security number you expect to find
exactly those things in there this gets
really fun when the suppose of the
discrete fields allow free text because
once you allow free text they will be
used to enter free text which means your
field that says for example lab result
might not actually contain the result in
the numeric value but it might see
something like so we looked at this and
we've done the first test and the first
has resulted in X and then the second
test resulted in Y just because there's
not a lot of enforcement of what
actually goes into these fields a lot of
times and then we have unstructured data
which is scanned letters for example a
lot of healthcare communication still
happens by effects so we get a lot of
faxes lab reports
like I said faxes and physician notes so
physicians also like to just sort of
write free text mr. X is a very pleasant
56 year old man who presented with XYZ
symptoms etc etc I actually have an
example of that so this is the kind of
what we call visit note for example or
physician don't you find a lot of times
in electronic medical record systems and
this is clearly like very unstructured
text quote the second one that's also
sort of the bane of my existence gaps in
data and and honestly like for me coming
from a background where I spend a lot of
time integrating data from external
resources where you basically have no
idea what people are going to do with
that external source so does the classic
data science we generate our data in the
house we're looking at log files or
click rates on our websites and if like
an e-commerce for
example that's a beautiful sort of
that's greener pastures this is sort of
the real world where you where you just
have to kind of accept the stuff that
you get and you have absolutely no
control over it
so one of the reasons why specific in
health care a lot of times you have gaps
in data is because patients tend to see
multiple clinicians either they might
get a second opinion somewhere right or
they might just switch collisions
because they're not happy with one or
they might move or in ecology
specifically we have something we call
snowbirds which is people who sort of
during the summer live and center villa
north and like say illinois and like
colder climates and then in winter
migrate down to Florida for example so
you have people who continue treatment
who continues to see physicians and it
might just have different different
locations they visit totally normal
the problem is if you rely on that data
for your analyses you'll have gaps in
there and a lot of times you might not
even know that you have the gaps right
EHR migrations so the HR field is very
there's a lot of development I I do have
a couple of sentences about like sort of
the history of EHR development but
basically clinics just change their EHR
systems because they don't really care
about sort of data consistency and and
and you know the data from like five
years ago for patients that they might
not be seeing anymore so a lot of times
they switch from one piece of software
to another piece of software and just
throw away all the old data because they
don't care about it anymore
based on my experience we had to do a
lot of convincing a lot of work to get
practices to keep any data that's even
older than two years because they said
we haven't seen this patient in two
years we don't we don't want the data
what do what are we gonna do with it and
we had to convince them to say well you
can keep it it's not going to make your
system slower but it might make life
easier for us so just keep that in mind
like a lot of times the people who are
generating the data for you don't
actually care about the data and they're
happy to just throw it away and the last
thing is workflow changes against
something you have no control over that
happens a lot in healthcare you might
have for example you might
stop seeing infusion data for an
oncology clinic so they do chemotherapy
infusions on-site you see drug
administration's drug infusions just
happening and being documented every day
and in one day they just stopped why is
that we've the G had to get on calls
with with Li clinics and ask them so
what what what happened there while
you're not documenting this anymore oh
yeah we just signed a contract with
another site and all our patients now go
to this other infusion site to get their
infusions they are now using a different
system and that works for us because we
don't care about the data so those kinds
of things happen too which is again you
have no control over and the interesting
thing in that case is it's not like oh
our database crashed and we have to
bring it back up from a backup and then
everything is fine again
no it's Lachie this this data I will
never come back like does it stops and
all these all the future patients will
go to another site and that's it like
and those are the sort of like gaps say
you haven't data that you I have to
detect and then B once you know that's
the case where are you going to deal
with it and it's it's a really tough
question so just as an example we have
like I kind of talked about the patient
journey a lot this is just sort of a
contrast of what's happening in the real
world and what you might be seeing in
the database and like I'm not a doctor
so please do take again take this with a
grain of salt this is just based on what
I've seen in oncology so what has
happening you might have done some
testing at the primary care provider
which is sent to an outside lab the
patient gets referral to clinic a clinic
a does more tests and then diagnosis the
patient the patient gets treatment and
recurring tested clinic B at cleaning a
for some reason like I said for example
might just move patient continues
treatment at clinic be patient might be
hospitalized and then might even be
referred to Hospice also the site node
working oncology is actually kind of sad
sometimes you look at the data but you
do see the people behind
it and occasion it's hard to deal with
so this is what you might see in your in
in the EHR of clinic B so assume you
have a contract with clinic B to
actually integrate their data to do some
data analysis on that so you don't see
anything from the primary care physician
you don't get any reason for the
referral there might be a mention about
this about what happened previously in a
visit note at clinic beam might be
backfilled the date might be off the
data might be off you're not quite sure
right the physician just sort of entered
that there might be mentioned in a visit
note about the treatment that happened
at clinic a then if you do start getting
data from coming B that's great there's
recurring records and visit notes you
might get another mention of a visit
note about the hospitalization but
generally there's no interoperability
between sort of smaller community
practice and hospitals so that data
might also just be mentioned somewhere
or not and then you might also never
find out about that referral to Hospice
so the data just sort of ends that you
see this is terrible but also pretty
typical this is kind of like the
patchiness of the data that I've seen in
the past third we have data silos so a
data is physically hard to access a lot
of times you have a oncology clinic or
community clinic has a computer with the
database with a sequel server database
or something that runs the EHR that runs
on the three computers at the practice
that's pretty much it how do you get
that data from my experience working on
flatter and one of the things that we
did is we had we'd Lachie had physical
boxes there that's that basically
provided a proxy for us to access to
them and pull the data and believe it or
not there people pull the plug on those
boxes too so those are the kinds of
things that you have to deal with this
like actual physical access there's no
necessary no data model or coding
standards so if you manage to integrate
data from let's say EHR a at a hospital
a
and then you want to do the same thing
at hospital B with HR B it might just
look completely different I'm saying no
in air quotes there are data standards
in healthcare for what's called hl7 for
example for sending messages I have a
lot to say about that it enforces sort
of the format of the data like the
structure but again in the same way as a
field that says lab result might not
necessarily contain the exact lab result
that you're looking for in the same way
8:07 might not enforce the actual
content of the fields necessarily and
due to all this scaling beyond a single
institution is really very hard so you
kind of just have to take it one one
place one database one physician at a
time I'm just gonna mention this this is
kind of ambiguity in medical text and
acronyms abbreviations longitudinal data
sequences is really hard this is one
thing obviously honestly where I think
this is exactly what computers and
machine learning and all that is
therefore to like figure out ambiguity
on that that's kind of what we're good
at
right like once we have the data and
then actually turn to understand what's
there if we know that data is like
fairly complete and everything that's
sort of you know more of a technical
problem that we can actually solve and
then lastly I'm sure a lot of you if
you're in healthcare you've heard about
HIPAA we can't just dump data into the
cloud there's a lot of extremely
sensitive data there's a lot of concerns
you can't just you know slack someone
hey can you look at patient XYZ and see
what's going on with that data said it
kind of looks weird right like there's a
lot of even just for like a typical sort
of data analytics workflow there's a lot
of barriers to data sharing for example
linking datasets and mapping entities is
really limited so you have one data set
and then you want to let's say link it
to another data set that usually
requires a lot of times in order to map
entities in order to link data for the
same person
you actually need their personal
information of some
sorts that you can't do right it's it's
really hard it's not like you have let's
say click click data for that person
that's kind of locked into that browser
on one website and you can easy link it
to another profile and another website
based on an email address like that you
can't do and then finally like I already
said like sharing and validating data is
really hard because you can't just like
slack someone an entire patient record
and say hey does this look cool to you
very quick sidebar how do we get there
why is health care data such a mess
so EHR adoption so electronic health
record systems are extremely like new
there this is this word legit just at
the beginning of the adoption this came
kind of with the high tech act in 2009
which is sort of part just of an
economic stimulus after recession in
order to encourage each our adoption so
this this whole technology it's been
going on for a really long time but mass
adoption has only come in the last 10
years so super new and it encouraged it
our adoption so physicians would get
incentives for actually using electronic
systems to document all their data but
it did not no one really cared about
interoperability at the time so it's
kind of like cool you all go and use the
system and and you know use your
computers for that and then we'll figure
out what to do about it later and the
main reason for that was because data
and machine readability was mostly an
afterthought it was really just about
interoperability in terms of oh this is
all in a computer now instead of a
physical file so we can send the whole
document to another person at another
hospital this is awesome this is solving
all our problems it was really just
intended for people to send it
electronically it was never meant for
anyone to actually for anyone and by
that I mean for any computer to actually
interpret it I keep calling clarified
paper
it basically is that like it's great
that it's not on paper anymore you don't
have to fax it but you can email it
problem-solve also one of the things
that's
really pains me to see occasionally
because we are so extremely spoiled when
it comes to UX in terms of consumer
applications like Facebook and my iPhone
and new Mac OS everything just worked so
well and so seamlessly if you see
physicians using electronic medical
record system you see them painfully
just clicking and clicking and clicking
and using dropdowns and you know it's
all I explained this talk to a friend of
mine a couple days ago and say they're
still using horizontal scroll bars and I
grew up with the internet and 90s and
horizontal scroll bars even then we're
like the worst possible thing you could
do but it took me it sort of describes
like how backwards some of the
technology is I mean the interesting
thing is because the clicking is so hard
this encourages dictation which again
kind of takes away from like the nice
and set of discrete data to just having
full text that might just be messy and
then finally there's also no incentive
for physicians to actually document
anything in structured form if it's not
needed for billing why would they spend
they didn't go to med school to type
things into a computer they went to med
school to treat patients right and this
is actually going to be a topic of the
next part of this talk is sort of like
how do physicians interact with other
China medical record systems so TLDR
getting clean and reliable healthcare
data as input for any kind of analytic
application is really hard and scaling
data access and standardization across a
single institution was also really hard
so going back to my initial tweet every
time I saw all these academics I'm
talking about so we implemented this
thing at our Hospital and this is great
I was like this is awesome and this
works exactly for your hospital and
probably nowhere else because any kind
of infrastructure that you have to
actually get the data and process the
data on any kinds of assumptions that
you have about the shape of the data
won't work outside of this institution
that you've you've built it for oh I am
running very late okay
other private reluctant users okay white
doctors hate their computers this is a
the title of a really amazing article
that I read I'm gonna sort of breathe
this mostly just based on quotes from
some amazing articles so first of all
data entry slow sorry for me mention it
just now one doctor and this article
says most days I will have done around
thirty to sixty percent of my notes by
the end of the day so if you think about
it means that computers actually
increase the workload of physicians
there are some studies out there about
increased burnout rates for example
there are sort of linked to increased
workload which is linked to increase
adoption of computer systems and an
increased need for documentation alert
fatigue is a really huge problem in an
ideal world again thinking sort of with
our machine learning hats on it'd be
amazing to alert physicians and
clinicians for example if someone is at
risk of sepsis the number of people I've
talked to who implemented sepsis warning
or sepsis alert in their hospitals that
it it must be double digits at this
point it's a very popular topic but a
question is sort of how many alerts do
we really need as an example so this is
a fantastic book called a digital doctor
and there's a description of how and our
system was implemented a hospital and of
thurmond fifty thousand medication
orders per month pharmacist was
receiving pop up alerts and nearly half
of them they means 50% of the time
anything you do you get a pop-up alert
if you you all use computers you all
know how annoying pop-up alerts are and
at some point you're just going to start
ignoring it right one fantastic point
that I heard from Carrie Anne Berg from
antigen who actually talked at ml conf
was kind of inspired this whole talk she
said great we now have AI to detect more
spinal fractures but is our Hospital
actually equipped to deal with more
detective spinal fractures we had now
have to treat and diagnose even more
patients like do we even have that so so
insights and then what right like you
and again coming from like a technology
perspective you're like oh my god we can
alert all these people of all these
amazing things
but then what happens this is where we
touch the real world and the real world
unfortunate EES moves extremely slowly
and you have to talk to a lot of people
you have to build a lot of
infrastructure and processes and
operations around instead of
implementing actions based on your
insights and then finally also again one
of the problems I think especially with
ml that a lot of people are starting to
get more aware of a sort of the black
box problem or transparency explained
ability a lot of times especially when
you aim at users that are not
necessarily a technology natives they'll
be like where does this come from like
why should I believe your algorithm
right again from my perspective maybe
sort of something that we're already
thinking about and maybe something a
problem that we can actually solve with
technology cool so the TLDR for this is
really it will take more in continued
effort to convince clinicians that
computers are helpful not just painful
like I said it's only been 10 years as
well we've been 10 years since is our
systems have kind of taken off I should
probably add like a little graph to this
to actually show how it's sort of
exploded all over the scene this is an
extremely new field which seems kind of
crazy because you kind of think this is
not a big deal entering you know data
into a computer those has been going
since you know the 80s or 90s but just
keep that in mind not like technology in
healthcare is actually a fairly new
field and it's it's difficult finally
passed forward so don't give up just yet
I basically told her told you guys like
don't don't even bother at Tech so way
forward No so there are paths forward
this is my very biased and very sort of
personal sort of view and perspective on
where I see opportunities for healthcare
data and I i've actually split it into
how to deal with the technology or the
messy data problem the technical
challenges and then also how to deal
with sort of like what to do on the
users side so first of all on the left
hand side this is
a busy site on a technical side on a DSi
be prepared like expect inconsistent
data I hope that from all the horror
stories that I've just told you this is
kind of sunken in like don't expect your
data to just work if it goes down like
don't expect it to come back up it's not
something that you can just hit talk to
your data engineer to and be like hey
can you just reboot that server or like
restart the the database host know that
data but someone might have unplugged it
and it might never come back so one of
the things that from my perspective I
think helps there is like building an
actual really strong data engineering
culture not just sort of the the data
science side where you sort of inspect
your data to just be there and
functioning and nice and pretty but
really think about monitoring think
about alerting think about data QA think
about data assertions I was really
excited about the talk earlier today
about great expectations the data
assertion framework because that is
really something that in an environment
that's as brittle as healthcare data is
absolutely mandatory so you want to
detect and prevent data issues the other
thing there is also what I'm talking
about QA you need subject-matter experts
on there umm.we engineers think we're
really smart we kind of are but we have
no idea about any kind of medical topic
so please do work with your subject
matter experts to really tell you
whether your assumptions are actually
and your assertions are actually right
and then also have a plan B if your data
source changes if your data just
disappears if they pull the plug if your
clinic gets acquired by a hospital and I
move to a different system and that data
and how do you handle it how you do deal
with that like you just have truncated
data and what are you gonna do with it
right so that's sort of the technical
side it's like actually be really
prepared on the user side this is more
sort of about the applications that I
think have a future at this point in
healthcare data and AI one of the big
things and
if you look at these two together
practice workflows and administrative
tasks are very very similar this is not
decision support this is not anything
clinical it's not tallying physicians
how to treat their patients it's not
telling the patient's like what
treatment is best for them this is
really just addressing a lot of the pain
points around the administrative aspects
of healthcare mostly because anything
like cost management benefit management
insurance just figuring out as your
insurance going to pay for this on the
on the on the clinic side there's
something called revenue cycle
management helping clinics actually just
manage their finances things like that
that allows people to free up their time
and actually focus on their treatment
from my perspective and also from my
experience but I've seen these are the
things where a the user is extremely
excited to get help because it's really
painful and it's not what they went to
med school for and this is something
where there's like a huge space where
you can really make a huge impact things
like value-based care for example
particularly reducing hospitalizations I
think is also sort of a again there's a
lot of you know a lot of people trying a
lot of different things but I do think
there's a path forward here for
artificial intelligence triaging on the
patient side so again it's sort of the
same like a very similar thing right
predicting hospitalizations sort of on
the clinic side having like nurses for
example call up patients and saying hey
you should probably come in front
check in because you're high risk for
something on the patient's side triaging
in terms of the patient's actually have
a way to sort of you know get some
feedback on their symptoms before they
go to see the doctor before they go to
the ER that seems like a fairly low low
risk to some extent mostly because again
like I said earlier false a false
positive if you tell someone to go to
you are you might be wasting money but
at least you're
you know you're potentially saving
someone's life so if you're if you're
aiming for false positives rather than
false negatives there you might be on
the safe side it might be fairly low
risk and there's a lot of data out there
image processing just thrown it in
because it's a very very popular topic
and it has actually a list of Radiology
like a sesame ideology image there's
been extremely good numbers there is
been an extremely good result
also because from my perspective at
least Radiology's sort of slightly
outside of the the whole like clinician
talking to a physician I'm sort of realm
and it's more about they're already
staring at their computer all day I
actually got to see a radiology room and
it's so cool to look she's sitting in
the dark room just looking at images all
day so having some form of computer
support there won't be as intrusive as
like having it in the examination room
where a physician really just wants to
talk to a patient and not stare on the
computer and finally I think mental
health especially around like lowering
barriers and reducing stigma you know
for someone to admit oh I'm going to see
a therapist or even just looking for
therapists is extremely challenging
occasionally downloading an app like tox
but the talk space doesn't use any AI in
there it uses AI for patient matching I
think to therapists but it doesn't
necessarily use AI in terms of like
actually conversation but there's
something called yooper for example
which actually uses a chat bot I tried
it out and it's surprisingly good so
things like that I think just lower the
barrier for people to get any kind of
access to to mental healthcare I think
that's an interesting like extremely
interesting path forward for artificial
intelligence lots of information there
I'm more than happy to chat about all
this later I have office hours right
after the break I think that's it for me
we made it
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a fantastic question so from a
data organization perspective I talked
about how everything is like sort of
diverse and dispersed and and sort of
messy are there other countries for
example where systems are more
standardized so I know about the UK and
I that was my hope and I kind of assumed
oh yeah and I just they have all one
system interestingly the NHS is all
split into regional sort of sub groups
and they can determine what kind of
system they use so I actually talked to
an engineer at the NHS and she said the
data is just as messy as the stuff you
describe about the u.s. there are
initiatives and obviously because the
NHS is unified system those initiatives
are you know more potentially could be
more effective but there's also been one
that's already shelved that totally
failed to kind of unify all the data so
Part A is that and then you're talking
about hospital systems
I guess so hospital systems versus
individual practices that is definitely
a totally an option and in terms of or
it's definitely better in terms of
having a unified system and potentially
even having a unified like a single
place where the data is stored one of
the problem with hospital systems is
that a lot of times they don't just
start out with these are exactly the
sites that we have and we implement our
EHR system across all these sites and
then we're done and nothing changes but
a lot of times they actually grow by
acquiring practices and then we
basically face that EHR migration
problem where some of the practices move
to hospital systems and move to their
EHR and then just throw away the old
data and then you're kind of missing
historical data also it doesn't
necessarily guarantee that they're using
the same system there's specialties for
example that might actually stick with
other systems so potentially better but
still at least based on my experience
not reliably great it could still be
messy yeah great question
ooh great question
I'd have to i'd have to that's a
fantastic question this is also negative
I'm sure we've had success so the sorry
the question was do I have any success
stories of any of these issues where we
actually we actually fixed it
I'd have to I'd have to think happy to
think and then talk to you about office
hours about this sorry
great question no great point should be
more positive you had a question
stick with us
hi
so within health matters
place data and
but these
yeah that was a great comment about
again the positive like potential
positive aspect depending on the type of
data so specifically the gentleman
specifically mentioned billing data that
might actually be of much higher quality
because if the billing data is not
complete and accurate no one will get
paid and people would want to get paid
and so the quality there is usually very
high the problem that I see with billing
data specifically is that it's not very
interesting from a clinical perspective
because you might so for billing data
for example you might not get the lab
results or you might get an ICD code a
diagnosis code that says lung cancer and
ICD the International classification of
diseases which is a coding system for
dye for diagnosis medical diagnosis does
not distinguish between small cell and
non small cell lung cancer for example
which is a very common distinction you
have in in oncology so things like that
where it's kind of you have complete
data but now the medical depth is not
very interesting depending on your use
case but that's a that's a great point
there are different types of data sets
and depending on a use case and
depending on the needs different data
sets are useful for different purposes
[Music]